Hey, David, are landslide elections even possible
in the modern United States?
So there's a couple different considerations
here.
Understand that with the Electoral College
system, you can have a close popular vote,
relatively, and a huge Electoral College victory.
It can happen.
You can also have a popular vote win for one
candidate while they actually lose the Electoral
College.
As we have seen help Republicans multiple
times in the last couple of decades, including
most most recently, Donald Trump in 2016.
The reason in our country that you are less
likely to see these overwhelming landslide
victories right now, it's less about the system.
The system very much can allow an overwhelming
Electoral College victory.
It's more about polarization.
The entire country agrees on almost nothing.
I imagined when the corona virus was starting,
this isn't how naive was.
I was.
What an idiot, right?
We're not going to politicize a virus.
We're going to come together as Americans
and we're going to do what needs to be done.
And we're going to keep people safe and we're
going to speak logically and it's going to
be connected to the facts on the ground.
Boy, was I wrong.
And if the country can't even agree barely
about something like a virus so empirical,
so fact based, then it is very difficult to
imagine that you could have such lopsidedness
in the United States that you would see such
an overwhelming landslide.
Now, that being said, how we define landslide
is up to us.
And you could see this November what in the
modern era would be considered a landslide
victory for Joe Biden or he might lose or
he might lose.
Now, the bigger picture is that you have a
lot of people in this country and this gets
to critical thinking.
This gets the education that this gets the
media literacy.
You have a lot of people in this country who
will never vote for a Democratic candidate.
You also have a lot of people in this country
who will never vote for a Republican candidate,
regardless of their platform platforms and
regardless of what they actually stand for.
There are then a bunch of people in the middle
who will see reason, but it is tough.
It really requires fixing and changing a lot
of the systems that keep people in these filter
bubbles and echo chambers and such when we
look at how they are distributed around the
country.
That's where the potential for a landslide
really comes when you look at some of the
polling for the upcoming election.
And you see, wow. Trump is only up two in
a recent Texas poll from the Dallas Morning
News.
Wow. Trump is only winning in Missouri by
five, whereas he won in 2016 by 19.
Demographic changes, older voters dying, quite
frankly.
And immigration from Latin America coming
in could actually create a situation where,
you know, we've been seeing it for a while,
but it could be in four years and eight years,
in 12 years.
Texas could be a purple state that sometimes
votes for a Democrat.
Georgia could be a purple state that sometimes
There are others you could actually end up
with a Democratic candidate with more than
400 electoral votes.
But it will likely take some time.
The Republican Party will fight it with gerrymandering.
They will fight it with voter suppression
because they know they can't win on the issues.
The other thing to consider is it's not in
the interests of corporate media to have a
blowout election.
Imagine how many people would tune out if
in June all corporate media said this race
is over.
And, of course, they would never actually
do that.
But the corporate media has an interest to
keep it seeming as hard fought and close as
possible.
So for the foreseeable future, what do we
know?
We know that elections will at least be portrayed
as close.
And we also know that unless demographic changes
overwhelm the level of partizanship that we
have in this country, we are likely to see
contested alack.
We will put it that way.
Competitive elections for a very long time.
OK.
Last question today,